On the last trip I traveled, I saved a lot on hotels, and today I
will tell you about the methods that
I use to book the hotel at the best price and the best view, and I make
sure of the room or place
that I am going to before I go. At the same
time, this video will inform you if you are going to book a fake reservation
because of Facebook like Schengen or  Any other visa,
I will also tell you the method. Continue the video
until the end, because there are two very important things that I will tell you
at the end of the video.
Stay with me. Peace be upon you. Omar Mohsen from the Nology channel. I know if I am late for you, I apologize to you, and God willing, I will come back to you with stronger content than the
previous video. Today I request.  From me on the
travel channel, if you think about it, how do you book your
own patio? Let's start with a practical example. For example, I
need to travel for work on the 10th of January, until the 13th of
January. What I will do next is the first step. We will see where we will book a
hotel. The applications we have are the
Booking application. I will download the application from the
video description and we will start together.  And I am explaining to you today
on the mobile phone because I know that
most of you currently use the mobile phone more than the
computer. After we downloaded the application, we will open it
immediately. The interface in front of me will appear to me. If you
have it in English and you want to change the language to Arabic
or vice versa, or even want to change the currency, you will go
to the login button from below.  You don't see this
here, and we go down until we go to
the settings, and from here you can change the Arabic language,
leaving it, for example, as you want here, making it
English, or go back to the second application
and change the currency if you want, for example, to an
Egyptian pound or any other currency. In my case, I made
it Arabic and the currency is riyals.  Saudi, it is very important that you
log in in order to enter their
loyalty program. Any reservation you make will be registered with you.
I will log in and enter through Google. So, I entered the application and we go to search in order to
begin our journey. The first thing for me is that it tells me to
enter his face. You want to go. Where can you write to him?
Street name, area, hotel. If you know
the city as you want, then I am here. For example, I
will write. I will write here, Mecca, in Arabic, in English, as you
wish. I am here, going to Mecca. Start asking me, when do you want to travel? I can set the calendar. I am here. Choose, for example, I am going, as I told
you, from the 10th.  For the
13th, he is telling me that I am going for three
nights on the fourth day until Saturday, Thursday
and Friday. They will be the most expensive two days. I will set the dates. He will start
telling me, “You want one room, not
more than one room,” assuming that it is one room, and
I choose two adults here. Even if I have
a child, you don’t want to.  Don't write because sometimes
they increase the price because the child who comes and chooses a
search will start here, showing me all the
available hotels according to the one that Booking has. If
I am a hotel I have stayed in before, they will recommend it to me in the
beginning, and thus we will notice the cost of three nights,
their price is excluding this written tax, so here I
have the most important thing.  I have these three things.
Here I want to filter with what I have set as my budget
for the day or for the three days. The first thing I do is to
filter it, and from
here I will start to filter it. It is based on the price. Here I choose the price I
want. I want to pay a maximum of
150 riyals per night.  From 100 to 150 riyals,
here it will start smaller. This is the
second side until I reach 100. A little 200
riyals. Then I am like this. The room I want is
from 100 to 200 riyals. Note that there are
only four places left for this cost. Let us increase a little,
then I am the maximum.  Here it is from 100
riyals to 300 riyals in 57 places identical to what I
work of course. It helps me that I do not find
hotels that are very luxurious and very expensive in vain,
and I am wasting time, so I prefer a liter for many things.
I only want apartments or
hotels, and I do not want a specific rating, and all of these are
filters.  You can view it according to
interest, and when I start displaying the results, it will begin to reduce my
options to the 57 hotels in Wadi
Hotels that appear. Of course, from here you can
sort the hotels that appear to you according to the distance
from the city center, the stars, the rating, or
the price. Say first, and it will show you the cheapest thing in the
first place according to  The budget you have set
may be better for you. Of course, we will reach the very important point. Also,
sometimes, if you book in any city, it is
necessary that you take something that is close to the city center, the
first town, the old city, or the center of
the country. I mean, I am correct so that you can go to places
faster or take something that is close.  From the metro or an
easy means of transportation that takes you to the city center.
In my case here, I want something close to the
Haram, so click on the map. The map helps me
show me all the hotels surrounding the place
I want to go. Here I am from the three
lines below. I want a satellite to be able to.
I can see the places better. We will notice what the
map looks like, Wadi Al-Kaaba. If we zoom in,
as you can see, I will walk to the Kaaba. Since I put this amount in the night and at the
end of the week, it is difficult to find a club nearby,
so I will go a little further until I
find the closest hotel to the Haram, which is the hotel.  Abu
230, for example, for example, but of course, the distance is
as you can see. As you can see, this distance is
very long until I reach the Haram, and
therefore the clock tower is there. Therefore, there will not be much difference in the
distances, because most of the hotels, if we go
into their details, we will know that they provide a pass to
reach you, so I, for example, will see.  I will click on this hotel and I will start to find its
rating. It will appear for me here, and I will see its name
and the price of the three for what they charged me, exactly how much. The nice thing is that it does
not require an advance payment. This means that
you can go there and pay when you arrive at the hotel
if you do not have a visa or an online payment method.
Of course, this rating is very bad.  Of course, it is recommended that
you see a rating that is higher than that. I
will look for a hotel that we can zoom out to see something else.
For example, this hotel has
almost furnished apartments. Okay, this is considered
good. Its rating is 7.2 or so out of 10. The number of people is
important for us to see how many people rated this hotel.
In order to reach this rating, it may be 10 out
of 10, and there are only two or three, but what they rated and this is an indicator that
also informs you. If you are going to events, for example, like Dubai, and a hotel with a number of residents of 100,000 people, this means that this hotel is exhausted. The rooms you will stay in are exhausted. This is also an indicator. Sometimes it is also an indicator.  Negative and positive. Okay, so
we know that for three nights it will cost us 209
and 292 riyals and 52 taxes. I find that cancellation is
free and does not require an advance payment. This means that if I
go there to pay, I can cancel at any time.
Okay. We will click on the hotel to see
details about the hotel. I am here and he will confirm with me.  I have my
appointments and I start to go down and see the
pictures of the
hotel and I start to go down to see if I want to read
the reviews of the people sitting in the hotel. I click on this arrow to bring up people’s reviews for me. I click on it and I will start to see what
people’s reviews are. I can
filter it and choose the one who talks about topics.  Certain things
or things, if they are important to me, and I am
starting to know what people’s evaluations of the rooms are.
I think this hotel is suitable, but I have a question: do you have a
bus or not? I can go back and see the description. If your answer is not there, click here and tell them, guys, do you have a bus that will take us to the Haram?
All these matters are scheduled and will be answered
within 2 hours, depending on the hotel, of course. The
next step is to click on “Select Rooms” and it will start
showing me the rooms they have available. Of course,
if you are taking something close to the Haram, you will find
something called View of the Haram, something called View of the
Kaaba, and rooms at the beginning of the city.  For example, of course, their
prices vary. For a
double room, the area of ​​the room is 16 square metres. It is important that we
look at it, and if we press this, it will give us
the shape of the rooms in which we will sit. Of course, it is
very normal. In quadruple rooms, there are four people, four
single beds, and so on. After that, we begin to choose
the room if we assume that this room is  Suitable for
me, click on book, but before I click on
book, let us see this application. During your
trip to any country, the first thing you think about is where is the
internet so that I can use Google Map and go to the
hotel or the place I want to go, and
therefore you go to the airport and buy an exaggerated price line,
but the solution to this issue is  It is the
electronic or built-in SIM card, which is the name that you
download to your mobile phone, not holding it in your hand,
but through the application you buy it. The application provides this
service. It is called Air. This application is available on iOS and Android. The beautiful thing about this application is that this SIM card covers more than 200 countries and regions
in the world, so what  Don't worry, where are you going?
Most likely, the country you will find is available after you
download the application. You choose the country
from which you want to buy the line, or you choose the continent
you are going to, for example, the continent of Europe, and it brings
you all the countries. You specify the period of time you want to
go, for example, a week or three days, and the size of
the data.  What you want is 2 gigabytes,
and so on, and you can also renew if I finish with you. I am
going to try now to buy a Turkish line. Do you see how low the cost is?
After they downloaded it, it is
very easy for me to operate the line. They also have a loyalty program. Anyone who
downloads the application through you will take 3
dollars, and you will also take 3 dollars.  The issue is a win-win for
both parties, but make sure that
your mobile phone supports the built-in SIM card. One last thing, the
application supports the Arabic language and all
these languages. The issue is very easy. Let’s continue. Okay, let’s
go back again. I am here. It’s over. I have reached the reservation stage. I will
choose here. I want more than one
room. It is only one room. I choose “Book,” and I will start
entering the data.  If I had a membership
before then, the data will already be registered. I
click on the next step. From here, it confirms with me my
data. When will I go and when will I go? And so on, if I have special
requests for a room, for example, that should be
quiet. I want a baby bed and I cry. I add a special request
here and write it to him, and he can respond to me. He can or
After that, I can't leave. The
last step from here is up to me. When do you want to pay your
money while you are in the hotel and pay from now on
or what is the method? I can choose, for example,
my visa and the means of payment. Of course, not all hotels
provide the ability to pay when you go to the place,
nor do all hotels provide cancellation as you do.
I want at any time, but in the case
I chose here, it agrees perfectly. Click on Book
Now, and as soon as I click on it, it starts to
reserve this room for me. Assuming that you want to obtain a visa for any country and among the singers of this visa, you can reserve a room and you are not sure that the visa
will be accepted, so you make a reservation.  Similar to this, for a room that does not ask for
payment, but you pay at the place, and if it is not available, you can
book a room with fake Visa information.
This site is in the video description. You have Visa numbers
like this that you put in so that you complete and book
the room without paying money from your balance. If you are
not sure that you will travel or  Get the visa and we will come to
the neighborhood I wanted to tell you
about. It is not necessary to book from Bookin. I mean,
here you can go to Bookin and see the hotels
suitable for you and determine the price you want.
After that, you go and search on Google and see who
other sites other than Bookin offer a
better or possible price.  You contact the hotel directly
and tell them: I want to book a room. How much does it cost
per night? You can book by phone
and also pay at the place of residence. It is not necessary
to book directly from Bookin. You can book from any other
application, Agoda, for example, or Kayak, or any
application that you see in front of you, or
call.  Directly by phone, and I personally tried it
in one of the countries. Booking via
fondue directly gives me points. I can make
it a newspaper for the rooms after that or upgrade the rooms.
At the same time, its price is lower and the room space is
larger. It often happens that you book. You know the book, but it
helps you with the room locations.  Or you book directly
with the hotel and call it. It is very important that you change
your dates. This means, for example, if you have
three days in Mecca and three in Medina, you can
do the opposite and book all three
in Medina, and then the three in Mecca. You may find a
large price difference between the two, so it is important that you
Try the dates topic in order to reach the best price
for booking the room. But this was today’s video. I
hope you like it. Don’t forget to try the Air application. I think, God willing, it will make a big difference
with you on your international trips. Write to me
below in a comment which application
you use to book hotels and flights.
We also want to talk about flying. Tell me
in the comments below. Peace be upon
you. The last point is that I cannot close the video
without talking to you about it, which is planning the trip. This
was a template that I was working on on the notes in the
names of the passengers. The first day will happen. They
will move, and where will Egypt and
Saudi Arabia be?  Where will we move
? Where will we go on the day? What will we wake up at?
What time will we break our fast? To be honest, when there is a large number of
people, it is very important that you arrange everything, the food, the
way of the place you will go, where you will sit, how
long are you expected to do, what are the
arrangements and things that you need to make before?
Do not travel while taking the necessary things with you. This is what
I sent to all the people who will travel with you,
so everyone will be aware of the itinerary,
even the subject of whether you book
too. If there are reservations, why, for example, I have here in the case of Umrah. In order to
go to Al-Rida Al-Sharif in the Prophet’s Mosque, you must
book for a ritual. These things are important.  Honestly, it
helped me a lot in planning a trip that included
about seven special people. If you want this template as it
is, write to me in the comments under Peace be
upon you.